sorpresa en España el presidente del
gobierno Pedro Sánchez disolvió las
Cortes y adelantó la convocatoria
electoral prevista inicialmente para
fines de año
la convocatoria formal de las elecciones
aparecerá publicada mañana martes en el
boletín oficial del estado de forma que
los comicios se celebrarán el domingo 23
de julio de acuerdo con los plazos que
establece la ley
he tomado esta decisión a la vista de
los resultados de las elecciones
celebradas ayer Alberto el líder del
partido socialista obrero español Pedro
Sánchez se refiere a las elecciones
municipales y autonómicas del domingo 28
de mayo en las que el conservador
partido popular se convirtió de nuevo en
primera fuerza a la mayoría de los
españoles que ayer lanzaron un mensaje
muy contundente acerca del rumbo que
desean que siga su país y quiero también
Mostrar mi satisfacción porque eso se
haya traducido en la convocatoria de
elecciones generales mejor cuanto antes
en 2019 el social demócrata psoe tenía
un
29,39% de los votos frente a un 22,62%
del partido popular mientras que este
2023 el PP ha subido a un 31,5% y el
peso es ha quedado en un 28,12% de las
principales ciudades de España tan solo
Barcelona podría ser la única en no ser
gobernada por la derecha dependiendo de
los pactos en las elecciones autonómicas
de las 12 comunidades en disputa el psoe
perdería cinco con dos todavía por
determinar el PP tendría 8 estos
resultados han forzado a Pedro Sánchez a
un adelanto electoral visto como una
respuesta rápida para cortar la Euforia
creciente de la oposición